I love what you talked about when you
ran the marathon you realize how much
you were leaving on the table because
that is um I mean I think the the
unfulfilled potential is the story of
most people's lives it is it is and it
could have been the story of mine I tell
a lot of people people go what's your
biggest fear in life and my biggest fear
honestly was let's say this let's say I
don't care if you believe in God or not
I don't care so this this is play game
with me let's say let's say you're God
and we have a big [ __ ] long line of
people and I made to heaven 75 years old
of 300 pounds I made to heaven I worked
for ecolab my entire life spraying for
cockroaches that's what I did but I'm
dead I'm in heaven now and you are at
your you're judging us all now so we're
in line we're all sitting there in line
you have Adam brown here's a big board
up and you're talking to Adam Brown
about his life and you rip it down and
I'm next in line David Goggins I see my
name I see all this [ __ ] and God goes
hey you say read this man now I'm
reading this list and I'm seeing 182
pounds Navy SEAL Ranger School
motivational speaker changing lives okay
man pull-up record all this [ __ ] I'm
like that's not me man
and God looks at me and says the house
who you were supposed to be and my
biggest fear I visualized some crazy
[ __ ] my biggest fear is that one day I
want to reach a judgment of my life
someone something is going to judge me
what the [ __ ] I was supposed to be in
life and what I want now is that whoever
is judge me would ever judge me up there
I want them to have a board in them up
there right now
getting their pin out because you know
this person who judge listened to
everything supposed to know from the
time you're dead the time you know you
know time you're born tongues of dead I
want this person up there to be like
this up there write more about me saying
[ __ ] I know you could do that I I know I
can do that so I want to impress
whatever the [ __ ] is up there whatever's
going on in life I want to go up there
and not
have anything left on the table I want
to I want to drain my soul of every
[ __ ] bit of person I am